former army major rob shenton served for
12 years before being sent to
afghanistan
but it was his time here that left him
with severe ptsd
after his second deployment in 2012 he
tried to take his own life
for me
by the time 2013 came along that was
enough i i'd had enough and i
generally tried to take my own life
and as a result of that i ended up in a
mental hospital in beijing stoke in a
military ward
and
i knew that my life would never be the
same again
despite his trauma robb says he has no
regrets about what happened in
afghanistan
overall i was proud of what i did there
but now
and when seeing the news
i think myself as obviously a veteran a
former military person i feel somewhat
hopeless because there's nothing that we
can do
to help i think for me personally i went
there and i did my duty and i did my
duties the best of my abilities
other veterans take a harder line and
are angry as they see the taliban regain
control
to watch
today the
the forces the the taliban armed forces
literally going up the streets where
you can see where your friends and
colleagues passed away fighting for
their cause
they went unhanded you know there was no
opposition for them at all
to to go through that and watch them do
that it's quite heartbreaking um
we've fought hard and we've we've
brought a better
existence for the afghan people there
and
and for it to be turned around so quick
and easily it feels like we've been
in total 457 british military personnel
have died in afghanistan
the financial burden on british
taxpayers is estimated to be
approximately 22.2 billion pounds
but veteran support groups say the
hidden cost is on mental health
the images that we're seeing and what's
happening in afghanistan that actually
triggers memories for all of us that
have served there but for some you know
they'll be much more anxious and
not necessarily be processing it as well
as others
so we we've certainly seen more veterans
coming to us and asking for support and
obviously their families as well
with every tragic loss in afghanistan
came a familiar ceremony of death as the
bodies of the fallen were flown home
many veterans and their families are
left questioning was it worth it
charlotte lomas sky news